Because guess what happens if you have
two minds? You have two people based on
what?
>> We got god logic.
>> Mean I have to discuss with you once
again.
>> That's fine.
>> I don't I don't have to.
>> You're right.
>> I'm here with an honest discussion.
Let's have it. Why are we wasting time?
>> Jacob Hansen.
>> We have Jacob Ldas Mormon and Jacob
Hansen.
>> All Mormons Christian.
>> Uh if I said, "Oh, my dad over here, he
and I are the same being." That would
mean that [music]
Okay. If God was a singular being,
meaning he's only one person, this that
is a that is a heretical state.
>> I'm waiting on real
>> because that's what WE BELIEVE.
We're glad you're part of the family.
>> You'd [music] have to dump uh the dose
of God.
>> No, you'd have to line.
>> Here is what's about to happen.
We are going to be having a formal
debate. what a formal debate is. What
that means is this is not going to be a
Pierce Morgan dumpster fire. [laughter]
Okay? I know some of you guys like, I
just want to hear THIS. JUST LET HIM GO.
LET HIM GO, REF. It's not what's going
to happen. Okay? What we're going to
have is we're going to have an opening
15minute round from each speaker that is
going to go into a 10-minute rebuttal
round from each speaker. And then we're
gonna have 15 minutes each of
cross-examination.
What that means is in the rebuttal
rounds, it's intended to be a rebuttal
of what was said in the opening, not a
continuation of their opening. Uh and
the cross-examination, one person asks
question to the other person. Okay? So,
it's going to be a bit more formal. And
then, uh and then and then that'll be
it. So, um the prompt today is we are
discussing
with our LDS guest Jacob Hansen. Okay.
Um the conversation of the triune God is
the biblical God a trinity. Okay. It's a
very important doctrine for us for us
Christians all Christians of all
persuasion uh Eastern Orthodox Catholic
oriental Orthodox is the biblical God a
trinity and God logic is going to be
taking the affirmative. So he has he's
going to go first. He's arguing four and
then Jacob Hansen is going to be taking
the affirmative, the negative. Okay. But
before that, I just want to show you
guys something cool. God Logic didn't
bring a chef hat today.
But someone made me, who's the gentleman
that made me this Chef Rouslon hat after
after they saw me debate interracial
marriage with Joel Webbin? Uh, and so
should I should I put this on for the
I'm not going to wear that for the whole
debate. I'll just wear it for the intro.
>> Okay, ladies and gentlemen, [laughter]
warm round of applause. This looks
utterly silly, doesn't it? Warm round of
applause for our debaters tonight, Jacob
Hansen and God Logic.
[applause and cheering]
All right.
>> Uhoh. Uhoh.
>> Okay. So, God Logic is going to go
first.
>> All right.
>> Uh, you have a podium up there, sir?
>> I do. I do.
And so we got a clock up here for you,
sir. So you can keep an eye on the time.
He is going to make a 15minute opening
statement arguing for the affirmative.
>> All right.
All right. How you guys doing? You all
right? [cheering]
>> Praise God. Praise God. It's good to be
here, man. Thank you, RLaman, for having
us, man. Uh Jacob, my friend, thanks for
stepping in the pot with us. Um,
[laughter]
it's going this going to be a this going
to be a good round, y'all. But this
going to be a good round. As Rooline
said, this is extremely important. Uh,
the doctrine of the Trinity is one of
the most disputed doctrines uh in
Christendom. Um, when it comes to the to
the Bible, uh, it it it we we hear that
it's pagan. We hear that it's
polytheistic. We hear that it was made
up at the council of Ni. if you watch uh
Sneo or anybody like that uh you know so
remember don't get your doctrine from
the Dawa guys okay you're in the right
place okay so what is the trinity let's
break this down really quick the trinity
is the concept that there is one god
everybody say one god
>> one god
>> who exists as three persons say three
persons
>> three persons
>> so one divine essence one divine nature
that consists of three distinct persons
inseparable who are completely united um
in their action, in their will, in their
mind, they have the same divine essence.
Okay? And so what we're going to see
here is does the Bible teach this?
Because you're not going to see the word
trinity in the Bible. You're not going
to see that word. You're not going to
see the word triune in the Bible.
However, that's not how we come to
doctrine. If a word doesn't exist in the
Bible, it doesn't mean that the concept
isn't being taught there. For example,
we all believe that God is all powerful.
Is that correct? But another word for
all powerful is omni omni uh uh what is
it? Omnipotent. There it is. See, I
almost forgot the word. But uh so
omnipotent. But that word is not found
in the Bible. Yet God's omnipotence is
found all throughout the scriptures.
Right? So we can see that a concept is
taught even though a word is not
explicitly or verbatim right there in
the scriptures. So this is what we're
going to see. What we're going to deal
with since we know that God is one. He
exists as one divine essence. Uh that
essence is shared between three distinct
persons, father, son, and holy spirit.
We should expect both singular pronouns
and adjectives for God as well as plural
pronouns and adjectives for God. That's
what I would expect if God exists as a
plural being. So for example, I should
see things like in Genesis 1:26 where he
says, "Let us make man in our image
after our likeness." or in Genesis 11
when he's about to go ahead and confuse
the people at the uh the Tower of Babel,
he says, "Come, let us go down and
confuse them." So God speaks of himself
in a plural. And watch this. It then
goes on to say, "And he went down."
Singular. He went down and confounded
the people. Also in Genesis 1:26-27, it
says, "And God made man in his image."
Back to singular. Notice how he goes
from plural to singular. This is exactly
what we should type, we should expect if
God exists as a trinity. And so what
we're going to see here, we got another
few examples. Those are the literally
the basic ones. Usually people are
familiar with Genesis 1:26 and the Tower
of Babel example, but I hope today to
give you guys a few more examples where
God demonstrates himself uh uh using
plural pronouns and plural adjectives in
places that we probably overlook because
it's seeped in the Hebrew. It's not
going to be outlied uh uh uh uh clear in
the English. So for example, when we
have uh Job 35:10,
it says this. It says, "But none says,
where is God my maker who gives songs in
the night?" Now, that's in everybody's
English translation. Doesn't doesn't
seem special there, does it? But when
you look in the Hebrew, this is what it
says. For the word maker, it's in the
plural. The word is o, which is the
plural particle for assa, which
literally means my makers. So, this is
how it would read in the Hebrew. But
none says, "Where is God, my makers?"
If God was a singular being, meaning
he's only one person, this wouldn't make
sense to me. This wouldn't make sense
for God to be uh for the scriptures to
be referring to God as makers. Is this
polytheism? No. Because the scripture
clearly teaches that there's one God.
But yet, he's referring to himself as a
plural of makers. How is that possible
unless he's triune? Let's give another
example. We have Psalm 149:2. It says
this in the English. It says, "Let
Israel be glad in his maker. Let him
rejoice. Let the children of Zion
rejoice in their king." Now, king is
singular, but here it is. This word
again maker is oay which is the plural.
So again, it reads, "Let Israel be glad
in his makers."
[clears throat]
>> Makers. Let the children of Israel
rejoice in their king singular. So the
makers of Israel is also the singular
king in the Bible showing that the God
of the Bible exists as one in one way
and is a plurality in another way. This
is the doctrine of the Trinity. Let's
keep going. I got a few more examples,
y'all. This Bible I got I got I got a
couple for y'all. Man, let's We got Hey,
what's the only thing we do around here,
y'all?
>> Read.
>> We just read, right? We just read.
That's it.
>> You can't see.
>> That's it. That's it. This is
Ecclesiastes. [laughter]
>> This is Ecclesiastes 12:1. Watch what it
says, y'all. Remember also your creator
in the days of your youth before the
evil days come and the years draw near,
of which you will say, I have no
pleasure in them. Now, here it is. It
says, "Remember also your creator."
Right? This is in English. It we'll miss
it if we don't know the Hebrew. But in
the Hebrew, the word is, now bear with
me, it's Barakia. Y'all try to say that.
Barakia.
>> Barak.
>> Yeah, y'all. Good man. Y'all quick
learners, man. This word is the plural,
which means remember also your creators.
Now again, guys, the Bible is not
polytheistic. This is one God, one
divine essence who is continuously
described as multiple makers, multiple
husbands, multiple creators, yet is the
one king, the one God, the one
sovereign, the one entity that is the
creator of all things. Now, here's the
thing. This is how we know this. We know
that this isn't just some plural of
majesty or, you know, just some
figurative language because the Bible
explicitly demonstrates that there are
multiple divine persons that are
responsible for creating all things. One
of them being the Holy Spirit. Watch
this. In Job 26:13,
it says this. It says, "By his spirit,
he has decorated the heavens. His hand
has formed the crooked serpent. This is
Job 33:4. It says, "The spirit of God
has made me, and the breath of the
Almighty gives me life." This is the
spirit of God, ladies and gentlemen. The
spirit of God. Here it is again. Psalm
104 29 and 30. You hide your face, they
are dismayed. You take away their
spirit, their breath, and they breathe
their last and return to dust. You send
forth your spirit and they are created
and you renew the face of the ground. So
we have the Holy Spirit that is
explicitly identified as one of the
persons who's responsible for creating
the heavens and the earth and giving
life to all of creation on the earth.
Right? Now there's another figure we
know as the word. You guys who y'all
know y'all know about the logos, right?
This is all in notice. We ain't we ain't
quote the New Testament yet. We're still
in the Old Testament. I don't need the
New Testament to show you guys the
Trinity in the Bible. I I I'm I'm going
try to stay away from the New Testament
as much as I can. I might sneak in John
a little bit later, but for now, for
now, let's go ahead and see what the Old
Testament has to offer us. Let's go with
the word. And so, this is what it says
in Psalm 33:6. Watch this. By the word
of Yahweh, the heavens were made and
their host by the breath, the spirit,
the ruach of his mouth. So in one verse
we see Yahweh by his word and by his
spirit created all things. Does this
sound familiar? It should. Now we going
we going to sneak in John now. John
chapter 1 verse one.
>> In the beginning was the what?
>> Word.
>> And the word was
>> and the word
>> was God.
>> And he was in the beginning with God.
All things were created through him and
not one thing was made that has been
made without him. Amen.
>> So this is exactly why we see in the New
Testament, we see the apostles, we see
the church fathers. This it's it's stuff
like this, ladies and gentlemen, why the
early Christians came to the conclusion
that the one God, the one sovereign was
a multiplicity of persons. Because the
Old Testament established that it's
Yahweh the father, his word, and his
spirit that created all things that are
distinct from each other yet
inseparable. And so we have here in the
in the New Testament, we got second
Peter 3:5. Watch this. But they
deliberately forget that long ago by
God's word to theolog
and the earth was formed out of water
and by water. Right? Revelation 19:11.
See, this is what gets me about the
Bible. The Bible goes so far to even
classify the word as someone that they
know, someone that they witness, someone
that they've seen. Watch what Revelation
19 says. It says, "Then I saw open, and
behold, a white horse, and he who sits
on it is called faithful and true, and
in righteousness he judges and wages
war. His eyes are a flame of fire and on
his head are many diadems. Having a name
written on him which no one knows except
himself and being clothed with a garment
dipped in blood. His name is also called
the word of God. The word of God is a
person, a divine agent of the father,
who created all things, who was
sovereign over all things, who comes in
righteousness, clothed in clothed in a
garment of blood, judges all the nation,
and is identified as the word of God.
This is what we have, ladies and
gentlemen, in the Bible. The Bible is
clearly depicting that there is the
father, the son, the holy spirit, the
word, the logos, the ruach, the spirit.
all identified as the makers, the
creators, the husbands of Israel. Now,
even with all this being said, this is
what we get. The scripture is very clear
that there is only one God alone who
created all things. Watch this. This is
Job 9:8. It says, "Who alone
stretches out the heavens and tramples
down the waves of the sea by himself he
does this." Job 10 8-12, your hand
fashioned and made me altogether. And
would you swallow me up? Remember now
that you have made me as clay, and would
you turn me into dust again? Did you not
pour me out like milk and curdle me like
cheese, clothe me with skin and flesh,
and knit me together with bones and
sneeze? You have made alongside me life
and loving kindness, and your care has
kept my spirit. It's not multiple gods.
Job is talking to one entity. He's
talking to one God, one sovereign, one
almighty that he identifies as his
maker. Job 31:15. Did not he who made me
in the womb make him? And the same one
fashion us in the womb? The same how
many? One that fashioned us in the womb.
Here we go. Isaiah 42:5. Thus says the
God Yahweh, who created the heavens and
stretched them out, who spread out the
earth and its offspring, who gives
breath to the people on it and spirit to
those who walk. Who is the God who does
this? Yahweh. Who helps him do it?
Nobody. He does it alone. Isaiah 44:24.
Let's get it. It's even more clear here.
Thus says Yahweh, your redeemer, and the
one who formed you from the womb. I
Yahweh am the maker of all things,
stretching out the heavens by myself
and spreading out the earth all alone.
Guys, I'm reading it verbatim. If there
was any confusion, if there was some
council that helped Yahweh create the
heavens, if there was some other
entities separate from Yahweh that
helped him create the heavens and the
earth, he makes it absolutely clear
verbatim in unambiguous verse
[laughter]
in unequivocal statement
where Yahweh God himself says, "I
created it all alone."
Thank you.
[cheering and applause] This man ended.
>> Logic ended a minute and a half early.
[laughter]
>> Where the heck did my phone go?
>> All right. All right. No, he didn't run.
He just went to go get his phone. Relax.
Relax. Stop.
[laughter]
>> It wasn't that good of an opening. It
was a great opening. You're making a run
off stage. You found your phone?
>> No, it's okay. I don't I I can I can
find it later. I think I sent it down
back there when we were ming up.
>> Um,
>> cool. Give me a minute. I'm not get my
stuff up. Don't start time just yet.
>> Make sure I got my stuff ready to go
here.
>> How y'all doing tonight?
>> Good. Let me get this stuff there. We
good. People see what's on there?
>> No, not yet. Are we going in the back?
>> In the back. I think you can.
Is it on the screens?
>> There we go.
>> Hey, there we go. Hold on one second.
All right. All right. Ready to start the
time here? Um, get my timer.
[laughter]
>> All right. Well, I must say Avery is a
heck of a presenter. And it is a little
nerve-wracking uh going up against
someone with the nickname Chef Logic
[laughter]
because of how he cooks his opponents.
Now, now that seems quite appropriate
considering that trinitarians have a
long history of quite literally
>> cooking people who disagree with them.
>> So, here
all right, all right. Hey, [laughter]
those are Catholics. We can blame Trent
Horn.
[laughter]
>> [applause]
>> But in all seriousness, uh, big thank
you to Rouslon and to God Logic. These
are good men. No personal animosity in
this debate. Um,
>> can we start his clock? His clock's not
going. Uh,
>> oh, it isn't yet.
>> Yeah.
>> He deserve that. [laughter]
>> Deserve a little extra time. All right,
here we go.
>> All right,
>> we got the clock going.
>> We got the clock.
>> There we go.
>> All right, here we go. Here we go. All
right, so I actually want to start off
tonight's debate with a point of
agreement.
uh we actually agree that there are
three persons talked about in the Bible
and there is one God. No one no one here
actually denies that. But what does that
mean?
That's what we're actually going to be
discussing tonight. Now, a lot of people
find the uh trinity confusing because of
the incoherent language that's used by
trinitarians uh to talk about God. I
mean, trinitarians like Avery will talk
about God as a genderless threeperson
substance.
And he will refer to three persons using
the pronoun he instead of the pronoun
they. But hey, it's 2026 and maybe
Avery's a little confused about how
pronouns work.
>> I can't see.
>> So, let's clear this up. Did you see it?
>> Hey, last year Alex O' Conor had some
good jokes. So, I had some big shoes to
fill, guys.
All right.
Now, this is the word at the center of
tonight's debate, the word God.
And in the Trinity diagram that you're
all familiar with, in the middle is this
thing with the label God. Well, what is
that thing? Well, it can't be a person
because the persons are the Father, the
Son, and the Holy Spirit in the diagram.
What that means is that thing in the
middle with the label God isn't a who,
it's a what.
Now,
Avery will say that God is three who's
and one what. He will use the word
father, son, and spirit to describe uh
who God is. And then he will use the
words go that slide. Uh then he will use
the word essence, being, and nature to
describe what God is. Now, at first
glance, this actually is not an issue.
Who I am is Jacob. What I am is human. I
have a human nature. Now, we can have
one human nature that's shared by
multiple persons. We have three persons
up here who all share the human nature.
That's not a problem until we start to
apply a little logic. So if I have
[laughter]
if I have three persons
that all have a human nature, I have
three persons. If I have three animals
with a canine nature, I have three dogs.
If I have three shapes with a triangle,
I have three triangles. Not complicated,
right? Well, until we get here. If we
have three persons who share the divine
nature, all of a sudden Avery wants to
act as if you don't have three things,
you only have one thing. And so people
like Avery will play word games. For
instance, when Avery says Jesus is God,
that sentence can actually mean two
different things. It can be referring to
identity which is the idea that uh this
Jesus is the same being as God or sorry
yeah that Jesus is the same being as God
or it can refer to predication. This is
like a title where God is being used as
a title meaning that Jesus is a fully
divine being. Right? These are the two
different senses that it can be used. So
let me give some examples here. So if we
were to say um
if we were to say Jesus is God in this
sense of identity J equals G. Then we
say the father is God. That would be
Fals G. Now anyone who knows anything
about logic is that that would mean Fals
G or J equals G. Fals
therefore J equals F or in other words
Jesus is the father. But as we all know
that's modalism. Patrick, come on,
Patrick.
So, obviously, we we all reject that.
Okay, that's that's just crazy. So, um
we have to go to this idea of God being
used like a title. Okay, so I could say
something like John is CEO, Squanto is
chief, Jack is captain, or
the word is God. Okay, it's being used
like a title, right? To say that the
word is fully divine.
All right?
So
um
it is perfectly logical to say that the
father is God. He's fully divine. The
son is fully divine and the spirit is
fully divine. You can say that they are
God in that sense. Okay? Totally
perfectly fine. So tonight we're going
to actually compare two different
models. Okay. One of those models is
going to use the New Testament term the
godhead. Okay. That is a term used
throughout the New Testament. And in
this model, you have three persons who
share a single divine nature. And that
nature brings them into perfect loving
harmony as a single perfectly united
divine council that rules in unity over
all things. And as you can see, this is
totally different from polytheism with
its capriccious waring gods of limited
jurisdiction and power.
Now then we have one other model which
is the trinitarian model which is to say
and if you think this is a joke drawing
it actually isn't. This is the the image
there is actually what trinitarians came
up with in the medieval age to to
describe the trinity. Uh in this model
you say that three persons who actually
are the same being. But how can you
have three persons who are the same
being if having your own being is what
makes you your own person? If I said,
"Oh, my dad over here, he and I are the
same." That would mean that we're not
individual people.
Okay. So,
um,
let's see here. But here's where it gets
really bad. When the trinitarian model
starts to contradict scripture, for
example, if Jesus has a will, how is it
that Jesus says, or I'm sorry, if this
one being has a will, how is it that
Jesus says, "Thy will be done if he was
the same being whose will was being done
in the first place?" Also, why does
Jesus say he has a God? How can you have
a God and be God at the same time? And
if Jesus is God, how is it even possible
for God to forsake him? And what being
was it that Jesus was praying to if he
and the father are the same being? Also
Jesus clearly says that he has been
given authority by the father. If Jesus
was the same being as the father, how
could the father give him authority?
Also, if I were to ask Jesus who the one
true god is, do you know what he would
say? Well, we don't have to guess. He
said it. He said it was the not so
genderless person he called the father
and our father. In other words, for
Jesus, the only true God was a who?
Also, if Jesus was the same being as the
father, how could the father
be greater than him?
Also, if the son is begotten of the
father, how can they be the same being?
How can the same being be the begget and
the begotten?
Also, Jesus said he was going to his God
and our God, to his father and our
father. If he was the same being, would
this make any sense?
Now, to solve these problems, don't
worry, I already know what Avery's going
to say to this. Classic response is that
Jesus had two natures, right? He was
fully human and fully divine at the same
time. Now, here's the thing. I actually
think that sounds plausible. After all,
I am one person and I have two natures.
I am a father. I have children and I am
a human. So, I have a human nature and
the nature of a father. Cool. Two
natures, one person. But could I be a
human and a frog?
No, I couldn't be. See, here's how it
works. You have what are known as
mutually exclusive natures. What is the
nature of a square? Squares has four
sides. The nature of a triangle is to
have three sides. That's why you can't
have a square triangle. It doesn't work.
Okay.
So,
what about the uh my opponent's theology
as it relates to God? In classical
theism, to be divine is to have all
knowledge. Notice the square. To be
human, notice the triangle, is to have
limited knowledge. These are mutually
exclusive.
Uh to be divine is to be unchangeable.
To be human is to change and grow.
Anybody see the problem? To be divine is
to be uncreated. How could you be
uncreated and created at the same time?
I think that might those might be
mutually exclusive natures. But hey, the
hypoatic union, what we'll do is we'll
call it the mystery of the hypoatic
union and that makes all of this problem
go away. We can have square circles if
we just call it the hypoatic union,
right? Well, I don't think that that
works. Um,
what happens here is you end up creating
two Jesuses,
one fully human, one divine, and then
you talk about them as if they're the
same person. Now, here's the thing. This
is why this ultimately breaks down.
Aver will say, "In his human nature,
Jesus suffered on the cross, but in his
divine nature, he cannot suffer because
to suffer is to lack something, and God
lacks nothing."
Seriously, the idea here is that the
same person both suffered and did not
suffer on the cross. Also, how the heck
can you make an infinite sacrifice if
God can make this infinite sacrifice if
only a human is the one on the cross
that's being tortured?
Okay. Uh, next,
how about two minds um or power? Can
Jesus have all power and lack power at
the same time? Could he have a mind, a
single mind that has all knowledge and
that lacks knowledge at the same time?
Or did Jesus have two minds? Because if
he had two minds, we got a problem.
That's two people. Because to be your
own person is to have your own mind. If
you have two minds, you don't have one
person. You have two people. Okay? So,
he'll do this tonight. He's going to
talk about Jesus in his divinity and
Jesus in his humanity. But that just and
he says that's the same person. But
those are mutually exclusive natures. It
doesn't work.
But what about all these things in the
in the scriptures that talk about the
oneness, right? Okay. Well, first of
all, as a pointed out, he he believes in
uh plurality in the Old Testament. So do
I. You have Yahweh in heaven, Yahweh on
earth, the spirit of Yahweh. That's
three who's. Okay, agreed 100%. You also
have that in the New Testament with
Father, Son, Holy Spirit. But you have
this one what.
What the heck does that mean? Well, can
multiple persons form a single entity?
Yeah, we do it all the time. If we had a
court that had three judges on it,
that'd be the court. And we would say
the court singular has found the
defendant guilty. This is totally fine.
We have entities all the time that are
that are have three people that make up
the entity. So the three who's remember
this are the persons. The one what is
the entity. I'm going to call that for
our purposes tonight, the Godhead or in
the Old Testament was Yahweh. They would
use that word to describe God and it
could be described as three persons or
as one what. And Abel will agree God is
three who's and one what. I agree with
that. No problem at all. Okay. So,
but the trinity model wants to say that
those three persons aren't just a single
entity. They want to say that they
literally are the same being. And the
trinity the the consistent trinitarians
will say that that one being has no
parts at all even though it has three
persons.
All right.
This is why Richard Swinburn, by the
way, who may be the greatest living
Christian philosopher on earth,
recognizes, he actually disagrees,
unfortunately, with Avery. He says that
even if you regard the New Testament as
an infallible source of doctrine, you
cannot derive from it a doctrine of the
Trinity. Now, why would he say that?
I was just told that the doctrine of the
Trinity is in the Bible. Because a good
philosopher knows the difference between
a who and a what.
So to win tonight's debate, Avery must
prove to you using the text of the
Bible, not just that there are three
persons and one God. He has to get more
specific and show that the Bible teaches
that those three persons are literally
the same being.
But he has to overcome problems like
this. like how can you be the begetter
and the begotten and be the same being?
But he won't address these
contradictions. My prediction is is that
he will pound the table again and again
and says, "But the Bible says that there
is one God. There is no God besides
Yahweh. God is alone our savior. God is
our creator. That one God, he created
everything alone. All that." But you
guys remember this.
The word God can refer to three who's or
it can refer to one what. So if Avery
wants to say that the one God, the one
what that was a plurality of persons
created all things. Wonderful.
That's what we call the Godhead and it's
totally consistent with scripture.
What Avery has to do tonight, watch
this. He can't just say that there's
three persons and one God. He has to
specify how those three persons all are
the same being despite all the
scriptures that contradict that notion.
But he's not going to be able to do it.
And the reason why is for the same
reasons that Richard Swinburn looks at
the doctrine of the Trinity in the Bible
and he says, "You cannot derive this
doctrine from the New Testament. You
just can't do it." And so Avery is
stuck.
He's stuck because if he wants to say
talk about the three who's use the word
God to refer to the he three who's three
not one. If he wants to use the word God
to refer to the one what the Godhead
well then I'm just going to agree with
him.
But he's stuck trying to teach something
from the Bible that isn't in there. And
that is why the best philosophers and
scholars like Richard Swinburn will just
admit you can't derive the doctrine of
the trinity from the Bible. And with
that, I'll yield my time.
>> All right. [applause]
Okay.
So, now what is going to happen is Avery
is going to spend 10 minutes on a
rebuttal round. That means he is going
to be rebutting everything Jacob just
said. And then Jacob is going to go up
and have 10 minutes to do a rebuttal
round against him. And then we'll do uh
15 minutes each cross examination. All
right. Let us know when you're ready for
the clock, good sir.
>> Thank you. [clears throat]
Um, so first of all, I want to say that
Jacob is absolutely right. I'm going to
pound my fist.
[laughter]
>> Oh, shoot.
>> I'm going to pound my fist. And when it
comes to making these distinctions, now
he says, "I'm not going to address these
contradictions." Uh, I don't think that
these are contradictions. And so, let's
let's demonstrate how. So, for example,
and like Jacob is a very smart person.
He knows where this is going. So when he
says, "Well, Jesus has a god." Well,
what Avery's going to do is he's going
to appeal to the his human nature. Duh.
Yeah, you got me. It's pertaining to,
look, why would I do that, though?
Because the Bible says this in Jeremiah
32:27, it says that God is the God of
all flesh. So what happened to the word
who is also God, he became flesh. So
it's at this point when the father and
that that relationship, the father
becomes this God pertaining to his
flesh. He's not a separate deity than
the son. But in that relationship, the
son humbles himself to the father and
the father becomes his ruler pertaining
to his flesh. In Psalm 22, we all agree
it's about the it's about the Messiah
where it says that they pierced my hands
and my feet and you lay me in the dust
of death. In that same psalm in verse 6,
guess what it says? It says, "From my
mother's womb, you have been my God."
Not before, but once I took on flesh,
once I entered the womb, that's when
that dynamic was in place. not before.
So, this you're absolutely right, Jacob.
This is pertaining to the human nature
of God and that and and what that
entails in his relationship in that in
that dynamic with the father. What about
the next one? He says that you know how
can Jesus be the same being as the
father if the uh if he says that the
father is greater than I. Well, this is
this is beautiful. This is understanding
categories. For example, in the same
chapter, cuz he's quoting John 14:28 and
in the earlier verses in John 14:12,
Jesus says, "Whoever believes in me will
do the same works that I do, and greater
works than these will he do." Does Jacob
think that people are going to do better
works than Jesus? I don't think so. So,
what does he mean by greater here then?
Greater in quantity, not quality, right?
They're going to be doing more works
than he does. Because this is what Jesus
says. He caps it off by saying, "Because
I'm going to the father." He was only
here doing works for three years. But
the apostles and the rest of the
believers are going to be doing works
for the rest of their believing lives.
So they're going to be doing a greater
quantity of works than Jesus, not a
greater quality of works than Jesus. So
then greater in what sense is the
question. When Jesus says the father is
greater than I, is that greater in
essence? Absolutely not. But what this
is is again Jesus a humble servant of
the father takes the lowly position and
says you should be happy that I'm going
back to the father for the father's
greater than I. Why? Why? Why should
they be happy that Jesus is returning to
a place where someone is greater than
him in? Because locally the father is
greater than where the son is. He's in a
humble lowly uh uh uh state where he's
uh um you know uh doing his earthly
ministry work where he has to be
obedience even to the death of a on the
cross uh experience humiliation and the
death of a criminal. The father is in a
locally greater place than he is. He's
on his throne in heaven. Christ came
down. The Philippians chapter 2 says,
"For he made himself of no reputation,
but humbled himself by taking the form
of a servant, being born in the likeness
of men."
>> So, it's not greater in the sense that
he's greater God or greater in essence.
No, greater locally because Christ
humbled himself. HE'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
I'M POUNDING MY FIST IN THE HUMAN
NATURE. HE'S absolutely right. He's He
might be a prophet. I'm not going to lie
to you.
He He predicted my next move like crazy.
I'm telling you. What about when Jesus
says, "Let your will be done." And
that's okay because will is a product of
your nature. Again, Jacob is right.
JESUS HAS A HUMAN NATURE. SO THEREFORE,
he'll have a human will that he brings
under subjection to the divine will.
>> That's why he can say, "Let your of uh
but not my will. Let your will be done."
Right? which he in in this position,
he's feeling the pressure of the
crucifixion. He's feeling the pressure
of the despair and the uh and the um the
the grief of carrying the sins of the
world. Isaiah 53 already told us he was
going to feel this way. Isaiah 53 says
he's going to be acquainted with grief,
a man full of sorrows. So when Jesus
comes and incarnates and is facing the
pressure of the crucifixion and it's
imminent, it's coming. I expect him to
be like, "Hey man, listen. If if there's
another way,
between me and you, father,
let me know." But not my will, let your
will be done. He brings that human will,
that weak will under subjection to the
divine will. And this doesn't entail two
persons. It entails two natures that are
united in one person.
>> Okay. Uh let's see what else he said. He
says, "The father is the only true God."
Amen.
Absolutely. The father is the only true
gods. Okay, good. That is not a negation
of himself as also being true God.
Notice in verse one, this is what Jesus
says. That's verse three. In verse one,
Jesus says, "Father, glorify your son so
that your son may glorify you." Who does
he think he is?
Who does Jesus think he is telling the
father to glorify him
>> so that he then can glorify him in
return? What? You better glorify him
anyway.
But no, he talks as if he is in equal
essence with the father and there's a
mutual glorification.
>> So when he is glorifying the father as
the only true god. Amen. That's not
negating himself because he then goes on
to say in verse two he says for you have
given him all fle authority over all
flesh to give them eternal life. What?
Wait hold on a second Jesus. You ain't
god. You're you're not the almighty. You
can't give eternal life. You have to be
eternal to do that. But you're not
you're you're you know you were created
or you made or you got your divine hood
in some way, right? You can't say you
give eternal life. But no, he says I
give them eternal life to all you have
given me. So according to Jesus, it
sounds like he's fully God, right? And
not in just some title sense or no, he
by essence, by very nature, he has the
same nature and essence that the father
does. Matter of fact, it gets even
clearer with this. Hebrews chapter 1
vers3 it says this guys it says that
Christ is the word of the lord he's the
son by whom uh uh god created the worlds
and then it goes on to say that he is
the exact imprint of his nature
you mean to tell me that they don't have
the the bible doesn't teach they have
the same one one nature if he's the
exact imprint of the father's nature
that means whatever the father is of the
what that's what the son is too while
also being a distinct person. Where is
the Bible teaching this? Right here.
[laughter]
IT'S RIGHT HERE, BIG DOG. IT'S RIGHT
HERE, MAN.
It's right here. All right. Now, he
also, like, like I told you guys, I'm
going to keep saying this. This man
might be a prophet cuz he's smart. I'm
telling you, the man brought up an
example of the three judges in the court
and says, "See, well, you're going to
say the court says, but you know, it's
it's three different judges, right?" And
so he [laughter] was so smart that he's
going to say, "But but Avery, he doesn't
believe in partialism." And cuz he knew
this was partialism. But how? So this is
my thing with Jacob. He knew that this
was partialism and that I would attack
this, but still use the example anyway.
It doesn't match the trinity. So it's a
failed example to say, "Hey, see, you
can just have three people that are
identified as God and just say, "Yeah,
that's God." Like a council or like a
court. No. In Psalm 86, it says that the
council of God worships you. He ain't
part of the council.
>> They bow to him. They worship him. How
can Yahweh be part of the council if
he's distinct from the council that
worships him?
>> That's how the Bible is clear that
Yahweh is distinct from the council of
the gods, the council of the angels, of
the sons of God. He's distinct. He
judges them. He counsels, he controls
them, he makes decisions, he judges them
in Psalm 82. And so what we have here is
God, it says that he is highly exalted
above the gods. Highly exalted. It says,
who among the gods is like you? Who
among the gods? Among the sons of God
are the angels. Who among them has works
or deeds that are like Yahweh's? Guess
what? In Hebrews chapter 1, it says the
son. The son's works are exactly like
the father's. Matter of fact, Jesus says
this in John chapter 5. He says the son
can do nothing by himself.
>> Only what he sees the father doing. For
whatever the father does, the son does
it the same way.
>> Amen.
>> Jesus can do whatever the father can do.
Why? Because they share the same divine
essence.
>> So what we're going to have to deal with
is this. We're going to have to deal
with how the Bible explicitly identifies
three persons as creator, as makers,
sustainers, establishers, covenant
makers, right? Um um um formers. We have
to deal with this and then deal with
where Yahweh says, "I created all things
by myself. I alone stretched out the
heavens. Nobody was with me." And this
isn't him comparing himself to other
false gods. He's saying it as a matter
of fact. In Job chapter 9:8, he ain't
comparing himself to other gods. This is
Job strictly just stating a fact. God,
you are the one who alone stretched out
the heavens. But the scripture says that
the word created all things. The
scripture says that by the spirit all
things are created while identifying
them as distinct in their personhood.
How do we deal with this? God is triune,
baby. Triuine, baby.
>> All right.
>> [applause]
>> So, [cheering] Jacob is now [applause]
going to do a rebuttal round. You got
slides for the rebuttal round, too.
>> Yeah, I got I got some I might might
refer to. Let me see. Is this going
>> Do you want to swap so you can see the
slides?
>> Um,
>> or can you see them from there?
>> I can just hear them.
>> You sure?
>> Yeah. His presentation was just so
funny. I wanted to see it. [laughter]
>> It was It was killing us.
>> All right. So, Jacob is going to go 10
minutes and then we are going to go to a
15-minute cross.
>> What's going on? [laughter]
>> Oh, what happened? We'll get there.
We'll get there. We'll get to the
arguments. Wait, got more pictures of
God. All right. Um, hold on. Let's get
ready. Um, okay. Let's go ahead and
start. All right. So, here's the issue.
Um, those were actually really good
arguments if he was arguing against
someone who didn't believe that Jesus
shared a fullness of the divine nature.
I believe fully that Jesus and the
father are fully divine beings. So
acting as if Jesus wasn't fully divine.
Uh that isn't what I'm arguing. Um Jesus
has the fullness of the divine nature
right now. They are three beings, three
persons who share one nature. Okay, the
three of us right here, just you guys
know, we all share the same nature.
We're all humans, but there's three
persons here. Remember the trinity is
trying to argue that the three persons
and Avery has said this explicitly. It's
not just that they share the same
nature. It's that they are the same
being. That is a quote from one of his
recent videos. Okay. [laughter] And I
can I can I can pull it up. So that's
the doctrine of the trinity.
>> Okay. So he doesn't have to say that
Jesus is the Godhead model just so you
guys know fully says that Jesus and the
father share the same nature. Okay.
That's not a problem. Okay. The problem
is is that he wants to say that while
Jesus was on earth as a human, he had a
human nature and a divine nature at the
same time. He wants to say that Jesus
was a square circle.
That's the thing. Did he address that?
Did he address the mutually exclusive
natures? Did he show from the Bible that
those two natures actually are
compatible?
No, he didn't because it doesn't exist.
You can't do that. The Bible doesn't
teach you have square circles. Okay? So
let's just be very clear on that. Second
of all, he's acting as though I don't
believe that the Godhead is the most
high. All members of the Godhead, all
three of them can rightly be called God.
They can rightly be called the most high
in their in the fact that they are all
part of this highest entity. Okay, that
that's exactly right. Now, I want to
talk real quick about what the scholars
say about this. It doesn't mean that
there's all these multiple gods and
they're all equals. Like, no, that's
that's insane. That isn't what the Bible
teaches here. Our good friend Dr. Siguad
says it really well. He says,
"Historians like biblical scholars
including Peter Haymon, Nathan McDonald,
Paul Frederickson, Michael Heiser, Larry
Herado, and Richard Bachmann among many
others argue that ancient Jewish
monotheism was not a denial of the o of
the denial of other divine beings
existence, but rather an affirmation of
Yahweh's unique supremacy." Christians
conceived of divinity as a spectrum
rather than a binary. The key thing is
monotheism was not a numerical oneness.
It was a qualitative concept. Monotheism
is something which came later in the
17th century. Okay. So here is the idea
of what actually was taught in the Bible
in the old world when you actually study
it through the best scholarship to
actually understand what the ancient
Hebrews thought of. They believe that
they existed in a world with many gods.
But they believe that their god Yahweh
was the most high, that he was supreme.
That is what the godhead model teaches.
I already laid that out. Okay? And
Yahweh is a name that can refer to the
angel of Yahweh, to Yahweh in heaven, or
to the spirit of Yahweh or to all three
of them as an entity that operate and
create alone as an us. Is this making
sense? Like this all should ring right
true. Okay. Um [snorts]
and I do have some funny quotes. I guess
well you do have God Logic who says the
Bible teaches clear explicit monotheism
and then we have Michael Jones who's in
the audience who says I think terms
monotheism and polytheism are stupid and
should be completely discarded. He's a
heretic. That is that is his thing. He
says, I don't think you can use
monotheism or polytheism to describe any
religion. Right? So the the point here
is that the way to think of ancient
Israel is actually in terms of multiple
divine beings, but this divine trio as
the most high God. That is the way to
properly understand what the Old
Testament is teaching. And all three of
the members of that council are fully
divine. They share they are
ontologically in equal but they are
relationally
relationally they are uh have a
hierarchy. Okay. But they are
ontologically of the same kind. They're
of the same species or level. They're
they're fully divine beings. Okay.
Here's the thing. If Avery really wants
strict monotheism where there's just one
being, one God,
well, I got some bad news for him
because this is what strict monotheism
looks like. Islam. Now, [snorts]
it's actually funny. Dr. Siguad argues
that the problem with Islam is that it's
actually too monotheistic. He says,
"Islam explicitly presents itself as a
restoration of the original monotheism
of Abraham, Moses, and the prophets. But
Judaism acknowledged the existence of
multiple divine beings. Islam represents
a fundamental reversal of Judaism's core
onlogical claim, moving from multiple
divine beings existing under what? Under
one supreme god that consisted of three
persons."
Okay? One divine counsel. I'm not
talking about the divine council of all
the rest. Yahweh was the was the ruler
of the of the council of the gods. So
there are lower gods in the council but
the three at the top were the ones who
ruled over all and the father
relationally within that trio was the
most high. Okay. So he says they went
that's the problem with Islam.
So
um
again we have three who's and one what.
And right here this is it you guys. The
one what that can be called Yahweh or it
can be called the Godhead is what
happens when you have all three. But he
has to remember what he has to do
tonight. His burden of proof. He has to
show that they're the same being. Not
just that they're a a trio of individual
persons that rule over all things in
total unity as the Godhead model would
would would propagate. Now, I'm going to
also
ask some questions you guys need to
think about, okay? because Avery hasn't
really addressed these. Okay. One of
them is, can you be a man and a woman at
the same time?
I know it's 2026, but I think we all
know the answer. No, you can't. Why?
Because those are mutually exclusive
natures. Okay. So,
um,
divinity and humanity, you can't be
created and uncreated at the same time
in one person. That one person was
either created or he has always existed.
If he has always ex existed, then that
is a divine person. That is not a human
person. Okay?
You have to understand this idea of
mutually exclusive natures. And if Avery
does not do that, well then he's in
trouble. By the way, did Jesus pray to a
who? Or did he pray to a what?
Did the ancient Israelites pray to a
who? Or did they pray to a what? Do you
pray to a who? Which who?
There are three who's
okay.
Um
Avery actually said that the father
generates the son. Avery has also said
and I quote to be self-existing is to be
ungenerated. Wait what? The son is
generated but the son is al so
self-existing. You guys, that's a
contradiction in terms. You can't be
generated and be self-existing. Okay.
So, is is the son self-existing or is he
generated by the father? And if he's
generated by the father, hold on. I
thought God is the the uncaused cause of
all things. Oh, the the son is not the
uncaused cause of all things. He's
generated by the father. You guys, you
have to reconcile these. You can't just
say, "Oh, my opponent seems to think
that Jesus is a lesser god or
something." I don't. Okay. The Godhead
model is quite simple. You have three
persons, the three who's and the one
what. When Avery talks and
cross-examines me in a moment, he's
going to ask me things about God. And
I'm going to ask him because remember
the word and and and Avery said this and
is quite explicitly the word God is not
univocal. It can refer either to the
three persons or it can refer to the one
what. Okay? So the one what is the
Godhead? The three persons father, son,
holy spirit. Here's the thing. When he
uses the word God, I'm going to ask him.
I'm going to say, "Avery, by God, do you
mean the one who or the three persons?
Are you talking about a who or you
talking about a what?" And if he doesn't
clarify that, that will expose the game
that's being played.
Okay? You have to clarify your terms.
The key to understanding why the trinity
doesn't work is getting clear on the
language involved. And the best way to
do it is with who's and what's.
Remember, you have three who's, you have
one what. any one of the three who's can
be called God or the one what can be
called God. When we talk about the
oneness of God, what are we talking
about? We're talking about
the Godhead, the entity. When we're
talking about the who's, we're talking
about the individuals. And with that,
I'll yield my time.
All right. [applause]
So, this is probably the part that uh I
think we're we're most excited to see.
This is the crossexamination round.
where they will get to ask each other
questions. There will be two 15-minute
rounds.
Avery will be asking Jacob questions.
Jacob will be asking Avery questions and
that will conclude our debate. So, how
do we Who's going first in this? Is it
back on him?
>> Yeah, he first. Sweet. Okay, if we can
get a 15-minute clock and then uh we got
two more rounds and then Oh, let's start
that over because I'm I'm yapping.
>> Okay. When he starts, that's when we can
Hey, Jingle.
>> Hey. Hey. [laughter]
Okay. Uh, all right. Cool. So, um, let
me ask you this question, man. Um, who
do you believe Yahweh is?
>> You talking about a who? You talking
about a what?
>> Who? Who is he?
>> Who?
>> Yeah. Out of the person's is the father
Yahweh.
>> Each one of them can hold the divine
name. So, in Exodus, for example, it
talks about uh my name is in him.
>> The angel of the Lord.
>> Yep. To the angel of the Lord. So any
one of the three persons can hold the
title or name of Yahweh as they in in
the so in the ancient world there was a
concept of the king sending a messenger
that would bear his name and who would
who would actually speak as if he were
the king in uh the the in uh revelation.
Uh John sees an angel who comes to him
and begins to speak to him literally
saying like I am the alpha and the omega
and he falls down and starts worshiping
him.
>> That's not an angel. Well, no. Well,
well, the thing is is he goes, "No, no,
no." He says, "Get." He's like, "What
are you doing? Get up. I'm a fellow
servant."
>> Yeah, but you said the angel says that
I'm the alpha and omega. That's that's
Jesus speaking.
>> Well, I might be misquing, but he's b My
point is is I might be messing that part
up, but he is what he is doing is the
angel is speaking as if he is Yahweh.
>> No, he's not. What What gives you that?
>> Why is Why did John fall down and well,
John falls down and worships him and he
says, "Get up."
>> Yeah. So, what happens in the context,
John is in awe of the vision that he's
seeing. And so it just says that at
being in awe of this, he then falls down
before the angel's feet to worship the
angel. And then the angel picks him up
and says, "Hey, don't do that."
>> Why was he Why would I mean I can't ask
you those questions, but the reason that
he's asking or that he's falling at his
feet is because the messenger is coming
as if he is God.
>> No,
>> there's nothing in the context that says
anything like that. So it, like I said,
he's showing him the visions and the
heavenly places and the the events
that's going on. John is in such awe of
this that he's he falls down to worship
at the end
>> and begins blaspheing by worshiping an
angel.
>> Yeah, he makes a mistake. He makes a
mistake. That's why the angel said back
to your question.
>> All three members can bear the title
Yahweh as the messenger of Yahweh. They
can bear the divine name.
>> Are are they Yahweh though? Is the
messenger Yahweh?
>> What do you mean by Yahweh? The one
what? Or the
>> is he? So again, when you're saying that
that they can bear the name Yahweh,
you're saying they can bear the name
like it's a title that they walk into or
carry out their their duties.
>> Yeah.
>> Are they Yahweh though?
>> Well, are you are is Yahweh a who or is
Yahweh a what?
>> He's asking me a question, man.
>> Oh, I'm sorry. I need No, I'm trying to
understand the question cuz when you say
>> No, no, no. He's asking the question.
>> I know, but I don't understand what he's
asking.
Would you agree that Yahweh I mean
Yahweh can refer to a who or it can
refer to a what?
>> Okay. So when you say u uh somebody can
go out in the name of Yahweh. How are
you using Yahweh in that way?
>> In that way.
>> Yeah.
>> When someone can go out in the name of
Yahweh.
>> Yes.
>> I would say that they're using it in the
sense that they're going out in the name
of the father.
>> Okay. Why?
>> Because the father is the within within
the godhead relationally. He is the most
high.
>> I got you. So to you, the person who is
Yahweh by reference and by like who
Yahweh actually is is the father. The
son isn't really Yahweh. He's just an
agent that can carry the name of Yahweh.
>> Incorrect. No. Yahweh can refer to a who
or it can refer to a what. If it's
talking and and it does refer to a who
is the father and the father's name can
be born by by the other two members.
>> Okay. Is is the son referred to as
Yahweh? Is the son referred to as
Yahweh? Yes. Okay. So, if the son is
referred to as Yahweh, can the son also
send someone in the name of Yahweh?
>> It's a good question. Thank you. Um,
I admit that's a good question. Um,
because he bears the divine authority.
Yes, he can. He can send people out in
the name of Yahweh. Jesus does that. He
sends people out in the name of God
because he's Yahweh. That's why.
>> Well, no. [laughter]
No, but you know, here's the thing.
That's just not to understand the notion
of divine agency in the Bible. The idea
is is that the angel of the Lord is the
angel of the Lord Yahweh. No, he's not.
I'm asking this rhetorically. The angel
of the Lord is not Yahweh. He's the
angel of Yahweh. He's the messenger of
Yahweh, but he's treated as if he's
Yahweh. Okay. If you have a king who can
I stop you there? Yeah. Go ahead.
>> Okay. So, the the angel of the Lord, you
agree that the angel of the Lord
appeared to Jacob in Genesis 31, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> In the dream, remember? And he saw the
stairway.
>> Yeah.
>> Who in the scripture does it say he saw
at the top of the stairway?
>> Yahweh.
>> Very good. So is And then in Genesis 35,
we get that the angel comes back to
Jacob in another dream, right? Remember
the they're doing the cattle thing, the
spotted thing or whatever. And he says,
>> "I am the God of Bethl, the one who you
made a vow to." Right? In Genesis 31, it
was Yahweh that he made a vow to. The
angel of the Lord comes to him and says,
"That was me." Right? So with this being
said,
>> is the angel of the Lord Yahweh?
>> The angel of the Lord can bear the name
Yahweh because No, no, no. The you have
to remember when a divine messenger
would go forth for the king in their
context. Remember, you guys are reading
this through a modern lens in the
ancient world, the king would send
someone out who would bear his name and
speak as though they were the king in
order to let people know what was going
on. And they would bear the royal name.
They would speak literally as if the
king was there. They were the king.
>> Would they claim to be the king?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. If they were if they were if if
they were in the way that they would
speak, they would speak as though they
were the king.
>> No, but I that's different. I know they
can speak as though they were the king.
They come in the name of the king. They
make it clear. Hey, I'm a representative
of the king, right? Can they claim to be
the king himself?
>> But you're you're operating with the
word Yahweh exclusively as a
>> question. No, no, but the word Yahweh
has you said yourself that the word
Yahweh and the word God is not univocal.
It can refer to my question. It can
refer No, but that's the problem is that
you're asking a question without
defining the term that you're asking.
You're conflating the term Yahweh is a
who or the term Yahweh is a what?
>> Let me tell you my my handsome friend.
This is what [laughter]
this is what just happened. What I did
was is I went by your terminology just
now. I asked you when you say that
Yahweh sends a messenger out and they go
in the name of Yahweh, how are you using
that? And ever since then, I've been
going about how you're operating using
the word Yahweh. Okay. So, with this
being said, I'm asking, can the
messenger or agent of the king claim to
be the king?
>> He can. If he's using the name Yahweh,
he can claim to be part of that divine
counsel.
>> I don't care about the council. See,
we're doing it again.
>> No, no. And I'm not deferring to the
divine counsel. from returning to the
godhead. Any member of the godhead, he
can say he can say that I am Yahweh
because Yahweh is a term that can refer
to God.
>> That's what I'm asking. Here it is
again. Can the agent of the king who he
sends out, hey, go to nation number and
go talk to the people or whatever. Can
that agent that the king sent say, "Hey
y'all, I'm the king." And I say boop
boop boop. Can he claim to be the king?
>> He can claim if if you're referring but
you're referring to the name Yahweh in
this case.
>> No, brother. The king. Can he claim to
be the king?
>> I'm talking. But this is all in
reference to Yahweh. And Yahweh is a
word. The Yahweh. No. Yahweh is a word
that can refer. He said he's Yahweh,
right?
>> Jacob the king.
>> No. No. No. He said he's Yahweh.
>> No. Yahweh. I'm using your example.
You're see this is what happens.
>> The problem is that the king the king's
name in the case of Yahweh can refer
>> in the case of Yahweh
>> it can it's referring to Yahweh. The
word Yahweh is a word that you yourself
has said can refer to a what and if he
goes and says yes I am that what like I
am the I'm in the divine counsel I I
bear that name they can do that
>> okay so let's pause here for a second on
Yahweh okay
>> the king
>> yeah [laughter]
>> for your example the king
>> can the agent of the king claim to be
the king
>> no he cannot
>> thank
>> [cheering]
[applause]
>> But hold on before we get before we get
too excited here. I just want to make
sure we realize that was an example
apart from Yahweh. When we're talking
about Yahweh,
>> no, we're talking about Yahweh. And
Yahweh is a word that can be used in two
different
>> Let me let me let me show you. Look,
Jacob, let me show you again what the
problem is. Just like you did it with
the court with the court example and you
even recognize it doesn't work with the
trinity. Your example here doesn't work
for Yahweh because your example showing
that people can go as agents of the
king. They can't declare to be the king
themselves. The same way Yahweh can send
agents but the agents cannot claim to be
Yahweh or else they going to drop dead.
>> Okay. So w with with with Yahweh. So for
example, you say that Yahweh is the
father.
>> You also said that the son is also
identified as Yahweh.
>> Yes. This means that this either the
scripture is committing blasphemy or
Jesus truly is Yahweh the same way the
father is. How do you reconcile that
>> when you say that y that well no when
how do you reconcile? Go one more time
with the question.
>> So if you say that ju just like how we
we just demonstrated an agent of the
king cannot claim to be the king. You
cannot point to an agent of the king and
say that's the king right there.
>> Right? In the same way, you can't point
to any agent of Yahweh and say that's
Yahweh or that agent claimed to be
Yahweh themselves. Okay? So, if you're
acknowledging, you acknowledge that the
father is Yahweh, you also acknowledge
that the son is also identified as
Yahweh.
>> Either the Bible is committing blasphemy
and or Jesus is truly Yahweh in the same
way the father is. How do you reconcile
that?
>> They said they both are ontologically
Yahweh. They both ontologically are of
the same. No, that is not. I [laughter]
believe you're you're to say no to have
the same nature to have the same nature.
I believe that they're all ontologically
equal. You have to show that those three
persons actually are the same being.
>> Would you agree that
>> not just that they're all ontologically
equals I believe they're all onlogically
equals. You don't understand what the
trinity is because the trinity actually
is to say as you said it's not just that
they share the same nature, it's that
they are the same being. So you have to
establish from the scriptures that they
actually are the same being. What what's
the only thing we do, Jacob?
>> Read.
>> That's right. [laughter]
>> So, um, let's do this really quick.
Let's go to let's let's get the Bible.
>> We're going to get the verse.
>> We're going to go to Prophet Nehemiah.
>> You got four minutes.
>> I know.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, this is Nehemiah chapter 9:6.
It says, "You
alone are Yahweh.
You have made the heavens and the earth
and with all their hosts, the earth and
all that is on it, the seas and all that
is in them. You give them uh life and
the heavenly host bows down to you." Who
is that?
>> Who?
>> Yeah.
>> So that's a Yahweh in this case is a
who?
>> That's what I'm asking.
>> There's only one who people bow to.
>> Is it a who? Is it a who? No. Yahweh in
this case is a what because it's
referring to the one what?
>> Oh, the one what. And what does this one
what consists of?
>> Three persons.
>> Okay. So, just so you guys know,
[laughter]
apparently apparently God Logic forgot
about that a court is a one what
composed of three separate persons. So,
he hasn't actually dealt with it and
he's just putting on a show for you
guys. So, [laughter]
>> it's a great show.
>> Okay. I I got I got a few more minutes.
He needs to show that the three persons
in the one court, the one what actually
are the same being.
>> That's the trinity, you guys. He's just
describing the godhead model and then
being like, "Oh, I won. That's the
trinity." No, it's not.
>> The trinity is the three persons who are
the same being. He hasn't shown that. In
fact, he hasn't dealt with all these
contradictions in the scriptures that
contradict that notion that they're the
same being.
He just got up and walked away CUZ HE'S
LIKE HE thinks that the father, son, and
holy spirit are all fully divine.
That's not the trinity.
>> If that was the case, by the way, guys,
then Mormons would be trinitarians cuz
that's what we believe. [cheering]
Hey, hey, if we tonight, if we tonight
resolve it and now Latter-day Saints are
trinitarians and now for can be
considered Christians. Thanks, guys.
We're glad you're part of the family.
You'd have to dump uh the Joseph guy.
>> No, you'd have to. No. No. The issue The
issue
>> I got two minutes. I got two minutes.
Okay.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Um you know, it's not
often that I just let someone take over
my cross like that. [laughter] But when
you're working for me, man,
when we on the same team like this, you
can talk all you want. Hey, Jo. Hey, by
the way, you guys think Catholics are
are uh are Christians and they don't
have to abandon the Pope, right?
>> You're right.
>> Oh, Joseph ain't no pope. [laughter]
>> No, he didn't kill that many people.
>> Oh,
>> let's get real quick. Real quick,
though. No, but but in all honesty, that
that is you have to understand what the
trinity is. Okay, go ahead. Go ahead.
>> Okay, so um you said that the father
alone is the most high. Is that right?
uh the father bears the title of the
most high within the relationship of the
godhead. Amongst the three Jesus said
that they are greater than him. So
relationally the father is the most high
but ontologically he is equal with the
they're the same uh fully divine beings.
They're both fully all three are fully
divine beings.
>> Okay. You you identified you identified
the father as the most high in between
the father son and spirit. Correct. Is
that correct? Okay.
>> Relationally.
>> Relationally. Okay. Um, when it comes to
the son,
where does he sit
>> relationally?
>> Yeah.
>> He's begotten of the father,
>> but where does he sit? Where's his
throne?
>> On the right hand of the father,
>> which is
>> in heaven,
>> which is Oh, sure. [laughter]
But but but it's unhigh. The Hebrew
Hebrews 1 says,
>> and he's there with the body, right? Oh,
sorry.
>> Yeah. He says he sits at the right hand
of of the majesty. Unh high, right? Is
there anybody higher than that position?
No, that's what that's like the whole
godhead model. It's that that all three
of the beings are the most high, but
relationally amongst those three beings,
you have
>> all three of them are the most high.
Huh? You just said that the father
>> Yeah. If I had the court made up of
three people that was the ultimate
authority in the land, that court would
be the most high.
>> But okay, so when you call you you're
calling the father, son, and the spirit
a council, the council of God.
>> I wouldn't call them I'm not I'm not
referring to them as the council of gods
talked about in Psalms. That's not what
I mean. I mean that before.
>> I know. But they're not the council of
the gods in that sense. I'm not
referring to that. They are they are the
council that rules over all things.
>> Okay, my time is up.
>> All right, so now Jacob is going to go
into 15 minutes of cross-examination
asking logic. Just so you guys know, we
got a hard out out of this room at 10:30
for our tech team and our audio video.
So, we may not get to uh questions.
Maybe we'll get to a few. So, just heads
up. We got to be out of this room at
10:30 contractually. Okay, go.
>> All right. So, Jesus and the father are
the same being, right? That's what you
said.
>> No. No. What? What do you say?
[laughter]
>> We both We both said that
>> they're the same being, right?
>> Yes.
>> Does Jesus have a body?
>> Yes, he does.
>> He has a body.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh my. Does So, if he's the same being
as the father, does the father have a
body?
>> Yeah. So, this is referring to his human
nature. He possessed a body and he has
the same divine nature, the divine
essence as the father. So, they're equal
or identical in their essence and with
their divinity, not his humanity.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Um, is Jesus's body in
heaven right now?
>> That physical body?
>> Yes.
>> So physical. So heaven [clears throat]
heaven is a physical place.
>> Well, I I I don't know about the
metaphysics of of heaven necessarily
like that.
>> Well, I mean, are are you going to have
a physical body in a in a non-physical
body?
>> It's a glorified body. So, agreed. But
it's not physical, right?
>> I I I don't know if I would categorize
it as that because it's glorified. So,
it's it's made spiritual. So there's
there's a lot of metaphysics that's that
>> when Jesus eats fish, that's all like a
physical thing that he does post
resurrection.
>> Sure.
>> Okay. And that body that body is in
heaven though, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I just want to get clear on how
this all works in heaven. So we have
Jesus in but that's just Jesus in his
humanity, right?
>> What do you mean
>> with the body? Jesus in his divinity is
divine.
>> The person Jesus possesses a body.
>> I know. But but but but how can God if
he's fully God have a body?
>> Well, the same way that the scripture
says in Zechariah 12:10, it says that
Yahweh was pierced. Yahweh, who you
identify as the most high God, is
pierced. That's a physical action being
done. That can only happen if he takes
on a body. So, the scripture tells us he
does this.
>> Okay. I I know. But what I'm saying is
you're saying that God has a body.
>> Yeah. Yeah. He the person of the son.
>> Avery, you're going to go Hold on.
You're going to go with that. That God
has a body.
>> Yeah. The second person of the Son who
is identified as God took on a body. He
literally says, "You have prepared a
body for me."
>> Awesome.
>> God has a body, guys.
>> Yeah. The second person of the son.
>> All right. So, cool. So, so God is an
embodied being,
>> the person of the son. Yeah.
>> Okay. But he's the same being as the
father though, right?
>> Mhm.
>> But the father doesn't have a body, does
he?
>> I I said no, he doesn't.
>> Yeah. So, they're they're not. So, but
they're the same being.
>> Yes. So, so again, Jacob, they they're
Look, let me tell you. So, I'll say it
again. [laughter]
>> They are identical in their divine
being. That's the being that they are
identical.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. So, Jesus takes on a
human nature and he's a human being as
well. Okay. So that's where the same
person you're not confl conflating.
>> Okay. Um, can a person be a man and a
woman at the same time?
>> No.
>> Okay, cool. Um, can a person have two
mutually exclusive natures?
>> Can a person have two mutually exclusive
nature? Sure. God did.
>> All right, guys. That's it. So
apparently God is a square circle.
That's what he's going with. And he's
calling himself God logic.
>> No. So I'm not saying that God is a
square circle. I'm saying that he
possesses a square and a circle
simultaneously. So with you with a
square circle, you're saying you're
trying to say
>> but then you have two separate things.
>> Let me land. Let me land. So what you're
trying to what you tried to did Well,
tried to do what you tried to do was
[laughter]
what you tried to did was
>> you tried All right. You tried you tried
to mix the square and the triangle as if
they're one thing. The square is the
triangle at the same time. No, we're not
saying that the divine we're not saying
that the divine nature and the human
nature are mixed. He has two distinct
natures who are that are united in his
person.
>> Okay, cool. All right, let's let's go
through this then. Um and we're going to
show the problems with that right now
because um does Jesus have one mind or
two? He
>> has one one divine mind.
>> He has one divine mind.
>> So he doesn't have a human mind.
>> I wouldn't say that the that the divine
person has a human mind per se. I would
say that um that Christ in his humanity,
he when he takes on a human nature, he
possesses a human soul. He grows as a
human, develops as a human.
>> I know that that's I'm asking about the
mind. Does he have one mind? That's what
I'm saying. Yeah.
>> He has one mind.
>> Yeah.
>> And is it fully is it a divine does it
have all knowledge? Does he have all
knowledge?
>> Yes. And just And just really then how
is that
>> Can I answer you in full? Oh my
goodness. So, so you you do have like
certain interpretations that would say
that Jesus does have a human mind and a
and a divine mind. I don't really
personally hold that view. Um I I I
believe that he has one mind, but I I
don't see how this is dealing with is
God a trinity in the Bible. You're
trying to attack the
>> Well, what I'm saying is is that you
have a you have a separate you have a
separate a separation within God. You
have you're describing two you're
describing two persons and you're saying
it's the same person, right? Because
that person only has one mind and that
mind is either divine, meaning it has
all knowledge and is omnisient and isn't
limited in any way or else it's a human
mind. He can't have two minds because
guess what happens if you have two
minds? You have two people
>> based on what
>> are you saying that you can have two
people?
>> What what is your justification for
that?
>> Uh you it's not my time to answer the
[laughter] question. We can go back to
that. Um, so real quick,
>> so I just want to point out here, Avery
thinks that Jesus has one mind
>> and that mind is fully divine. So he
doesn't have a human mind. So Jesus was
not fully human. He can't make that
claim because because you can't have one
mind that is fully divine and be a
human. If I had a fully divine mind, I
wouldn't be.
>> What is your justification for that?
>> Because to be fully human, you have to
have a human mind
>> based on what? When you're talking about
Christ speaking on No, no, don't say
that's fine. No, it's it's my time to
answer ask the question.
>> Oh my gosh.
>> All right. Can we make God suffer?
>> Can we make God suffer? Yeah.
>> Absolutely.
>> We can make God suffer.
>> You can hurt God. So the perfect being
who lacks nothing. Hold on. You're
really going with that.
>> For God is not God God is actually hurt
>> for for us. For for example, in Isaiah
chapter 63, it says that the people of
Israel rebelled against him and grieved
his Holy Spirit. Does grieve equal hurt?
Okay. So, you're saying, "Does grief
equal pain and suffer?"
>> Yeah, sure. But this is the problem.
>> Then you just conceded God can be hurt.
>> Then you just refuted classical theism
because God cannot change an emotional
state. If God changes his emotional
state, you have a changeable.
>> This is a description of God's
displeasure and he actually has
interaction with human beings. Even you
believe this. EVEN YOU.
>> NO, NO. I BUT BUT MY POINT IS this isn't
classical theism.
>> This is the trinity. This is you. Okay,
that's fine. If you want to go with
that, that is just fine. I just wanted
to stand. No, because if God You're not
saying that God is even God because
because God does God lack anything?
>> So, no, but for
>> Hold on. Can you Can you suffer? I'm
asking the question.
>> I know, but I'm trying to answer you in
full. You just asked me something.
>> What did I ask you?
>> You just asked me can God lack anything?
>> Yeah. Can God lack anything?
>> So, the answer is no. And so when even
when you would say that when the
scripture says that they grieved his
holy spirit and rebelled against him
that he's hurt when his people uh sin
against him. He's hurt when they break
his covenant.
>> That's fine. But what I'm saying is that
that isn't consistent with with with the
nature of God.
>> You would not equal that as a loss or
God is lacking something because he can
be grieved. Okay. Can God change?
>> No.
>> Okay. So he would change his emotional
state from not being sad to being sad.
>> It's an expression of his displeasure.
So it's
>> you're talking about a God that's
passable.
>> What What do you mean by passable?
>> Oh my goodness. The creeds that
literally say that God is impassible.
>> What do you mean by that? I
>> It means that he he can change his
emotional state.
>> So you're So you're saying that I'm
arguing that God changes? That's not
what I'm That's not what I'm arguing.
I'm arguing that Hold on, let me finish.
It would it would be a change if God
didn't grieve. It would be a change if
he didn't suffer at at his at mankind's
rebellion. Then he would be changing.
That would be like saying if God stopped
showing mercy, that's a change.
>> I I just want for every YouTuber out
there who understands classical theism
to to take this and clip it cuz that is
that is a that is a heretical statement.
>> I'm waiting on Is God is God is God
personal?
>> Yes.
>> Is Jesus tripersonal?
>> Uh no. He's one person who is uh with
the Trinity. He's the second person of
the trinity.
>> Okay. So, but God is trip personal.
>> You're conflating nature and personhood
again. Properties of the essence. They
have properties of the person.
>> Okay. Is the what makes the father
distinct from Jesus?
>> He begets him.
>> Okay. You said in the past that the
father generates the son. Do you believe
that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Um in a recent video you said to
be self-existing is to be ungenerated.
Do you believe the son is self-existing?
>> Yeah. So what this is where you're doing
a category error again. So in what in
the video that I'm explaining, I'm
making the distinction between the
properties of God in his essence and the
properties am.
So you you cannot be generated by
another being and still be
self-existent. You can be generated by a
person that you share the same essence
with. You're not and and you're still
self-existent because you guys share.
>> So the son is generated by the father.
Is he dependent on the father for his
son?
>> There's an interdependency there. So
like for
>> So the father is dependent on the son.
>> Yes. So for example, the father, let me
get the father's dependent on the son.
>> Let me finish it. For example, the
father is a is a father as long as he
has what? A son. So without the son,
he's not a father. So in order for the
father to be who he is, he needs the
son. Okay. So you're saying, so your
god, your god that you're talking about.
Your god that you're talking about. Your
God that you're talking about can be
changed.
>> He's a dependent being.
>> I never said that. Don't star at me, J.
>> No. No. Because he can change. He can
change his emotional states.
>> I didn't say that.
>> You said that sadness.
>> Yeah. Be having God being grieved is not
him changing. If he cannot be grieved,
if he cannot
>> If he goes from a state of not grieved
to a state of grieving,
>> if he doesn't have displeasure in evil,
then he changed.
>> Is the person his nature to grieve? Is
the person Jesus the uncaused cause of
all things?
>> Yes,
>> he is.
>> Yes.
>> Then is the person Jesus generated by
the father?
>> See, notice you're doing it again. I'm
about to help you tonight. I'm
>> No, no, no. Is Is the sun generated or
not? I'm
>> I'm telling you. Okay, this is what
you're doing. And this is what usually
people, you know, who people I deal
with, the mumoo, the Muslim. But Jacob,
you're better than them. Okay, this is
the category. They do this all the time.
They conflate categories of the essence
of God. Properties that belong to the
nature and then properties that belong
to the persons. So when we say Jesus is
generated, we're talking about his
personal relationship with the father.
The father begets the son eternally as
similar to how an infinite son would
eternally generate light. That doesn't
mean that light now is created. No. If
the sun is infinite in the sky, then
light eternally infinitely generates
from it. So as long as the father is
infinitely the father uh psalm 90:2 he's
god from everlasting to everlasting and
he's unchanging. So he's eternally the
father which means he eternally had the
son right so this is their relationship
personally. Now when it comes to their
essence Jesus in his essence is not
generated by anything outside of his own
essence. So that's how he's
self-existent. Okay.
>> So in your view can God be a dependent
being?
>> God is a dependent independent being.
Did you ask if he can be a dependent
being?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, sorry.
>> Okay. So, can God have not within his
essence?
>> Sorry.
>> Can God have parts?
>> He's not made of a parts.
>> What does this have to do with the
trinity?
>> Uh, it has a lot to do with the trinity.
You're talking about you just said that
you have three persons. I want to make
sure I understand this. You have three
persons who are dependent on one another
for the same for that one being. And
then you're saying that God has no
parts. You literally just described a
dependent relationship amongst three
different persons and then you're saying
that there are no parts in God. But you
wouldn't have God if you didn't have all
three of the persons you just described.
You just described three parts.
>> No, I didn't do it again. You're having
to dance on this one cuz divine
simplicity negates the idea that you
have three persons that are ultimately
generating.
>> Jacob, the problem that you're having is
you're mixing up the operations and the
functions of the persons with each other
to the essence. And now that meaning
that they that the essence is broken up
into parts. No, they fully possess the
divine essence. They fully are God,
right? They fully have the divine
essence and their operations are
distinct. So the father begins, the son
is begotten, the spirit is proceeded
from, right? This is the operations of
them and their relationship. That
doesn't mean that they're now their
essence is broken up in parts.
>> The thing is is if you have something
with no parts, how can they have
relationship between the different
things? And when you're talking about
parts, you're talking relationships.
You're literally talking about
relationships. So you have to have two
things to have a relationship.
>> You're talking that's part that's parts.
>> When you say parts, you're talking about
the essence. That's what you're talking
about. But unfortunately, you keep
conflating the essence.
>> You're saying that within the essence
are three persons that are all dependent
on one another.
>> Refuse me from the Bible.
>> What I have, [cheering] Dude,
>> the thing is is that the God you're
describing can't be God because he's a
dependent being.
>> Give me the verse. GIVE ME THE VERSE.
>> Give me the verse. [laughter]
All right. So, how can you be both
begotten and unbegotten at the same time
in the same being?
>> Very good question, Jacob. I'mma do it
again. [laughter]
>> I should have gotten in that whiteboard.
>> Ladies and gentlemen, you can be
unbegotten via your essence because
there's not another essence or being
that generates you. That way, you're not
begotten. Then you can be begotten in
relation to the persons that you share
the same essence with. So the father who
has the same exact essence as you can
generate you eternally and it not be
multiple gods or partialism. So Jesus
can be begotten in one sense in relation
to the father and unbegotten in the in
the relation to his essence.
>> And he's going to literally say that
there are no parts involved in this.
>> That's not that's just distinct
operations of the persons. You can't
have operations between things if
there's only one thing.
>> You can have operations between persons
who share the same essence. You have to
demonstrate that just because they have
distinct operations or they're the
distinct persons that this means that
the essence is now divided.
>> To have anything be distinct is to have
two different things.
>> No. No.
>> No. Okay.
>> Yes, it is. You can't have a YOU'RE
TALKING YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT REAL QUICK.
You're talking about relationships
between things. How can you have a
relationship between things if you only
have one thing?
>> For for example, your soul is in
relation to you as a human. Your human,
right?
>> My soul is in relation to me as a human.
>> Yes. Right.
>> Go ahead.
>> Your is that correct? Your mind your
mind is in relation to you as a human,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Yet you're one human, right?
>> But I'm made of parts.
>> Now, I know I'm not saying I'm not
saying that's my point. Listen, let me
finish. I'm not saying that this is an
example of the trinity. I know that's
partialism. I'm addressing what you just
said. You just said you cannot have two
distinct things in relation to one thing
and it still be one thing. But yet you
have multiple distinct things and yet
you're
>> I'm made of parts. I'm not God. That's
all part
if you're saying you literally are
saying that Jesus has a physical body
and God doesn't have parts
>> and so
>> and the you're describing YOU'RE
DESCRIBING PARTS. MY PROBLEM is is that
if God of the Bible has the nature that
you claim the God of the Bible has, then
it can't have the things that you're
describing it have. And that's why the
trinity ultimately fails because it ends
up in incoherence with the god of
classical theism. You can't have three
persons and have one thing. And if god
is ultimately one thing and divinely
simple without parts, you can't have the
three.
>> So you're stuck in our bind.
>> That's our time, GUYS. [applause]
>> OKAY, we we're we're out out of time.
Oh, shoot.
>> Yeah, we're done.
>> No closing.
>> No closing. One final statement to take
us out. We got we got a wrap.
>> Okay. Okay. Um final statement, ladies
and gentlemen. So, uh Jacob spent his
entire [screaming]
cross-examinating not quoting a ver a
verse.
>> The topic is the trinity is the god of
the bible a trinity. He didn't refute
not one thing that I brought up
biblically, right? But tried to take a
philosophical route and was conflating a
bunch of categories. And so what we saw
was is that even under scrutiny,
biblically, it's the trinity is
biblically sound. It's undefeated. Even
philosophically, they can't stand up to
it. You can have three distinct persons,
be undivided
and inseparable and yet be one God.
Thank you guys for coming out.
>> All right, real brief statement.
>> My one final statement. Okay, here's the
thing. I showed in the Bible that you
have two contradictory natures and then
he needs well in his interpretation of
the Bible you have two contradictory
natures and he just owned it. He
literally just said that the father and
the son or that that Jesus is
essentially a square circle. Okay? And
the problem is is that that's nonsense.
And if you want to say that Jesus was a
square and a circle, you have two
things. You don't have one thing. Okay?
So if God is ultimately the one ultimate
cause of all things. If I had a Lego
house here, okay? And that house was
made of Legos, the house is dependent on
the individual Legos. So therefore, the
fundamental thing is not the house, it's
the Legos. He's talking about God with a
body. Oh, and he doesn't have a body,
and Jesus is fully divine, and he's a
square, and he's a circle. And he's
describing all of these different parts
within God. He's describing a God that's
dependent. He's describing a god that is
uh subject to human emotions and is is
and is a changeable being based on what
we do. And then he wants to claim that
that is the God of the Bible. And that's
the problem. That model of God is not
consistent with the classical theistic
God of the Bible that you guys want to
do. And so the thing is you can't have
the God of classical theism and the God
of the Bible at the same time. You can't
have that trinitarian model and that is
why it fails.
>> All right, Jacob Hansen, God [applause]
logic.